harry habe ich war die musik mp3 charts
in der branche
bei einem termin in lausanne julian dorn
im auge ist ihm herr harris einleiten
konnten donnerstag 455 heute haben wir
ultra viele sachen vor heute der tag
heute wird absolut fantastisch es ist
jetzt 14 uhr halb drei und in ein paar
stunden gehen auf eine premiere und
dafür muss ich mich jetzt fertig machen
und ich möchte ein video kopieren was
kann ich schon mal gemacht hat ich gebe
mir endlich mühe da schwingt sie sich so
extrem toll und macht sich die haare
verlängerungs dinger rein und es ist
extrem und ich habe auch lust auf eine
extreme veränderung und bevor wir das
machen mache ich mein viertes
adventskalendertürchen auf in dem
sonnenuntergang der schon fast wieder am
start
heute morgen habe ich schon fleißig
geschnitten ich habe ein bisschen
verschlafen bin um 9 uhr aufgestanden
aber ich war schneller einschnitt was
ist in kirchen immer hier drin
ein wunderbar schokoriegel und für eine
vegane bio leberwurst und eine achtung
als übung aber bevor ich die vorlese
muss sich timo bieten auch sein
adventskalender aufzumachen
manchmal noch mal deine nummer 4 auf
markierte auch gemacht
doch hast du doch stück habe ich ja was
ist der vierte du bist so wunderbar
keine ahnung wie das war die aus du bist
so wunderbar dazu connect das aber
wirklich gerade kannst du aber das kann
den schönsten lenz lehrkraft das motto
ist auch im gleichen tütchen das ist ein
gleichstand stand 124 dass wir es ins
gleiche türchen machen dass wir sogar
den gleichen riegel nehmen ist die
chance von 1 für eine million
heute gibt es eine rose bewusste
schmerzreiz übung reiz übung diese übung
kann nicht wirklich darauf einstimmen
wie sich dein körper bei unbehagen
verhält und welche gefühle dabei
hervorgehoben werden wirst rüthen
verstimmte passiert wenn die schmerzen
findest du dir selbst in den arm achtet
genau darauf wie sich das anfühlt und
was für gefühle du entwickelst achte auf
den ausgelösten schmerz und wie dieser
von stelle wo du dich in dein körper
ausstrahlt und dadurch soll man gucken
wie man auf schmerzen im linken regieren
doch voll krass auf schmerzen als auch
unbekannte schmerzen
auch die nicht mehr vorhanden werden
auch die nur in deinem kopf alle
schmerzlich wechsel jetzt die kamera
weil es geht los
die hat ihr euch gestern wo ich gesagt
dass ich ein paket bekommen habe hier
ist kenner werden schon wissen um was
für ein paket es sich handelt wenn sie
den rand sehen also bzw
sticker wo ich einfach aufgeregt ich
bewusst machen wenn ihr euch noch
erinnern könnt der free und shane haben
wir die neue cd herausgebracht und shane
dawson hat seine eigene lied palette von
erstmal bin ich auch gar nicht auf die
website drauf gekommen und dann wurde
ich irgendwann auch so eine
warteschleife gesetzt und dann habe ich
den laptop einfach daneben gelegen und
habe einfach gehofft dass ich noch was
kriege wenn ich dann irgendwann dran bin
und kaliber unterwegs und hat es an dem
handy versucht aber sie dann auch in
mein aufgegeben weil am handys ja noch
nerviger und jetzt angeschafft und diese
blöde palette ist in frankfurt am
flughafen oder so hängen geblieben und
der zoll hat es natürlich einkassiert
und hat aber nichts weiter gemacht da
kam halt keine neuer status dann habe
ich gedacht vielleicht hat auch jemand
einfach eingestellt jemand der sofort
erkannt und das ist konzipiert ist
oh mein gott ich wenn wir es keine
schutzfolie drauf haben wir haben nicht
alle immer die schutzfolie abgezogen
da guck mal wie auch haare in meiner
palette habe die ist riesig sie ist und
sie ist wunderschön ich weiß gab gar
nicht ich muss so bei oc glossy und
marvin gucken was gerade so trennt ist
ossi glossy hat immer die besten also
oscar hat wirklich so krasse lux und ich
bin jedes mal schickt mir sowas immer
arzt würde ich machen wollen ich gebe
mir endlich mal schauen was das bedeutet
ich habe jetzt mein gesicht ordentlich
gebürstet und retinol serum drauf
gemacht und ein hochbett erstmal jetzt
schöneborn wieder verstopften
[Musik]
meine hardware jetzt nicht so glücklich
aus aber wenigstens ist die glatt so
gern in flein soll sein sollte alles
meine haut rein machen kann und dann
werde ich mich auch mal wieder um euch
zu sagen dass ich dort lidschatten base
drauf gemacht hat die ganze scheiße soll
ja auch lange halten was ich hier jetzt
passieren würde dann machen wir aus sie
habe ich erstmal in root beer geht man
intern akon trainer kann ist diese farbe
hier schießt das ist das orange und das
kommt jetzt so knapp dran und da also
direkt in die lidfalte rein
jetzt nämlich dass wein brot nord effekt
das gleiche mache ich jetzt auch unter
dem auge
und dann neben dem lina so von außen
nach innen
jetzt bin ich relativ im karneval
eigentlich muss ich mir jetzt auch so
concealer aufs auge main und dann wieder
drüber
[Musik]
ich frage mich ob diese ganzen make up
trägt sie jetzt von dem ganzen beauty
gurus entstehen oder immer noch von make
up artist sie das professionell gewähren
haben blöd ist es noch nicht voll
probiert wer ist diese influencer rind
auf dem roten teppich und längst wohl
die nachbarn
ich habe man diese oehling nein das
mache ich noch so unten auf sie drauf
weil da hatte ich jetzt nur eine farbe
das ist auch so ein schimmer ich hatte
glaube ich noch nie so belegen das make
up
also jetzt kann ich bin so froh da
reingeben und jetzt geht es weiter
nämlich mit dem schlechtesten eyeliner
den hier gekauft habe und zwar ist er
von irgendwie er hat viel zu viel geld
gekostet und es richtig scheiße kreuz
nicht verpacken wenn ich jetzt verkaufe
[Musik]
geschafft ich habe mich gerade so viele
coole sachen erzählt während ich meine
augenbrauen an gemalt habe aber ich habe
die kamera nicht angemacht augenbrauen
mascara
beim kontrasten wir heute richtig aus
[Musik]
um einkommen habe scheiße ich habe das
ding viel zu lange drauf gehabt ja das
kommt mir jetzt keiner ab dass ich mir
mühe gegeben haben
meine wimpern ein tipp für künstliche
wimpern ich heute jemanden so meiner
hand hin und her damit sie wieder diesen
schwung kriegen wenn man sie so ein mal
abzieht dann werden sie wieder so gerade
[Musik]
als highlight benutzer von topshop hat
sich schon sehr lange ist gar nicht so
schwer
jetzt mache ich etwas was ich selbst
mache und zwar meine lippen linie nach
als lippenstift benutze ich den kreolen
lipstick
würde ich nur meine haare noch machen
also eigentlich wollte sie mir
verlängern
wer ist denn gerade beliebt auf
instagram wer hat denn nach haarlänge
die ich was bringt keine gennadi hat
doch so haare wie ich ungefähr
ich mag die haarverlängerung aber ich
mache nur ein bisschen herr verlängerung
und dann habe ich ein langsam auf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
marie ist button mit brad denn mit der
sie gar nicht so schlecht aus
hallo mein name ist ein sch
fotos ja gerne gut isst müssen wir noch
das outfit wechseln
ich gebe mir mühe ich gebe mir mühe
macht ist an dem film angepasst denn wir
schauen heute jumanji 2 timo hat gesagt
er ist zu wenig im letzten block an also
das ist bloß stellt das war es zwischen
uns das glaub ich wegen dieser
eingestellt ich glaube wenn zum beispiel
nur diese weise weil die so hängen das
tut dann nämlich auf die belichten
genauso er auch immer uns belegen hier
weil aber darauf den fokus ich gehe
immer mit offenem
so eklig das habe ich jetzt auch mal die
ganzen videos gesehen zu machen
aber kaum mit geschlossenem und fühlt
sich echt komisch an es sei nicht so
richtig mit aufnehmen kannst du das so
ich glaube jetzt ist aber mittlerweile
auch überhaupt nicht mehr schlimm dass
ich locker
es ist ja noch unangenehm von den leuten
hier vor den leuten war es bei mir neben
der unangenehm vor der kamera zu du
meinst von den 200.000 menschen die zu
schauen ja genau das war ein fahrzeug
von der palette auf die umgestellten
500.000 wochen gewartet hat
vollerfolg eurofighter zu sagen
[Musik]
du dir schon weg
irgendwer hat sie gerufen das bis jetzt
regenerieren
nein ich habe sich eben von ignoranz von
und angeführt von aaron werde immer
firma jetzt weiß er aber nicht
unfreundlich zurück ich komme auf die
nächste öffentliche führung
und kann auch nicht dahinter doch kann
man schon aber macht keinen sinn wir
laufen einfach schnell durch bei uns
wird ja eh keiner hält ja nur an wenn
dich jemand anhält aber uns hat ja
keiner anderen augen sind noch schöne
reiche palette das ist schon okay so die
kannst du juli kann zum science geben
wo ist er denn da sei leute ich hab
steven gätjen so jetzt können nach hause
gehen
super
die waren so
der spanische prinz dankeschön bringen
konnten
berlin
ich weiß ihr seid aufgeregt weil er so
viele stars oben stehen aber ich möchte
einmal dass sie wirklich richtig gas
gibt
[Musik]
manchmal ist in deutschland momentan und
dann sind wir nach hause gefahren
[Musik]
okay lasst uns nach hause gehen und
unanständige sachen machen sowas wie
putzen habe ich noch gar nicht gezeigt
den kranz an der tür
ich komme gerade nach hause
ihr seid auch schon hier ich habe mir im
taxi schon meine künstlichen haare
aufgemacht also zehn review wird zu
anfang
ich fand ihn gesehen hinter serien sind
auf jeden fall so dass letztlich kommen
wir nicht was aber megageil ja manche
ist richtig lustig gab es ja den ersten
teil vortage angeschaut und es war gut
dass wir uns lernen schavan ja so ein
paar fans ist das mit dem cache und so
dass man ja selten richtig verstand wird
nun im ersten teil gibt also war viel
notwendiger auch gut dass mir gesehen ja
und extra also ich fand ihn extrem gut
ich habe mein freund sehen sogar hast du
nicht gemerkt gelaunt ich manchmal
gelacht habe ich hab manchmal richtig
los gelacht aber so die diese hysterisch
gelacht das technisch nicht möglich weil
die ganze zeit verbringen wollten also
leute
was den wehgetan
ich wollte ich wollte nur in hättest du
das war ein cooler monats war schon aber
es ist erwiesen dass wir miteinander
schlafen so okay leute das ist nicht
mehr für die kamera jetzt sagen wir gute
nacht aber wir können jetzt wirklich
gute nacht sagen
das bedeute strikt an wenn ihr wollt ich
zeige euch nicht aber es lohnt sich auf
jeden fall ihr werdet gut lachen und vor
allem findet selber ist das ein guter
film so ein spaß für die ganze familie
und ich glaube ich werde nie wieder
darauf klar kommen dass ich einfach jack
black getroffen habe twain rock johnson
und kevin hart und carolyn das ist so
gemein ist sich den namen der frau nicht
kann
kerrin kevin weil sie im jahr war für
sie herr besser gesungen echo h sieht
das gerade gut aus ich habe nicht mehr
alkohol getrunken und finde mich gerade
so hübsch ist epileptiker das ist für
epileptiker gar nicht gut es tut mir
leid verzichtet er belegte körper gut
und ich erschieße jetzt ich mach dich
fertig sims kredite grenzt